[Applauso]
Allora come potete intuire dal mio
outfit dalla mia maglietta fucsia e
Daniele tacchi a spillo Io nella vita
restauro auto d'epoca
quindi magari vi immaginerete che io sia
qui a parlarvi di come da sola a 19 anni
abbia imparato senza avere competenze
specifiche a restaurare auto storiche
o forse magari alle difficoltà che una
donna deve attraversare nel lavorare in
un mondo che ancora prettamente maschile
oppure magari vi aspettate che io venga
qui a dirvi come potete realizzare i
vostri sogni e vivere delle vostre
passioni aprendo un canale YouTube
In realtà io oggi vi vorrei parlare di
un'altra cosa
quando mi hanno chiesto di partecipare a
questo Ted la primissima reazione è
stata Oddio che figata cioè che emozione
che onore neanche un secondino dopo ho
sentito forte e chiaro nella mia testa
quella vocina che insieme alla mia parte
razionale abita la mia mente
che diceva più o meno così
Se vabbè mo Tu che fai in Ted Ma dove
vai
tu che alle elementari alle recite
scolastiche ti facevano fare solo
l'albero per la tua discutibile presenza
scenica Tu pensi di andare lì e salire
su un palco
penso che la cucina non ha tutti i torti
però ho fatto anche tante cose
coraggiose nella mia vita alla fine come
sempre basterà un piccolo attacco di
panico tipo quello che ho avuto prima
qua fuori con una crisi di pianto ma poi
vedrai che mi farò coraggio
Ma che gli vai a dire a questi Ma che
c'hai da dire Tu guarda un consiglio
meglio se a Canni
accannare dialetto romano mollare
e allora ha detto va bene acanno Ho
scritto la mia bella mail di scuse di
ringraziamenti per questa bellissima
occasione
e poi mi sono detta Vabbè ma mo' a canna
Ma poi che gli dico la mia parte
razionale che ho avuto paura No dai non
esiste Tanto c'è tempo
alla vocina non ha fatto per niente
piacere di essere stata scavalcata non
le piace non avere il controllo
Allora per validare la sua tesi ha
passato quel mese di tempo a buttarmi
giù in tutti i modi a suon di non è
niente da dire non sei abbastanza brava
sul palco ti impappinerai perderai l'uso
delle parole scoppierai a piangere
andando via cadrai spaccando di tutti i
denti
inutile dire che c'è riuscita alla
grande a convincermi
cinque giorni fa 5 giorni prima di
questo Ted non solo non avevo un
discorso ma non avevo più le energie per
fare o pensare qualunque altra cosa
ogni volta che mi mettevo lì a scrivere
di un argomento mezz'ora dopo lo buttavo
era improvvisamente stupido e banale
come me pensavo
5 5 sono i discorsi che ho scritto per
poi buttarli nel cestino dei non è
abbastanza
abbastanza per chi poi
quella vocina nella nostra testa perché
lo so che ce l'avete anche voi
ha un potere manipolatorio Talmente
potente da riuscire a convincerti di
quello che vuole finché non diventa
realtà
come ne esci da una situazione così
quando perdi nella partita scacchi che
stai giocando da solo
quando a quei giudizi auto inflitti
credi talmente tanto da averli
trasformati in realtà
io ho pianto tanto
E poi magari ho pensato che avrei voluto
scrivere agli organizzatori che mi sono
rotta una gamba
poi magari l'avrebbero scoperto
Forse dovrei rompermi davvero
Poi visto che la storia della gamba mi
sembrava mezza dolorosa ho avuto un'idea
se lei la vocina mi impedisce di
scrivere di ciò di cui vorrei scrivere
scriverò di lei che mi impedisce di
scrivere e farò questo Ted e mi
risparmierò una gamba
come nel mito di Davide Golia non so se
ve lo ricordate il pastore che uccide il
gigante col Sasso
Ecco capisco che la paura il mostro se
non posso vincerla con la forza posso
vincerla con l'astuzia e la mia arma il
mio paradosso è il mio sasso e come
Davide glielo lancio in fronte sperando
di ucciderla a sassate la mia paura il
mio mostro il mio Golia
ve la presento ve la mostro la cucina
nella mia testa
la vocina nella mia testa ha la faccia
del mio cane
Il mio cane è una Alano di 80 kg con
ettari di pelle in eccesso che rendono
la sua faccia Qualunque sia la sua vera
espressione o un'emozione questa
Ecco capitate che stare chiusi in casa
da settimane a disperarvi a un certo
punto rotolandovi per terra per la
disperazione girarvi sperando di
incontrare lo sguardo rassicurante del
vostro animale domestico che in quanto
tale dovrebbe avere il solo scopo di
conforto e rassicurazione
e vedere lui dall'alto del suo
piedistallo che vi guarda così
non è il massimo
Sono sul pavimento io lo guardo lui mi
giudica
Ecco adesso Se conoscete Zerocalcare
sapete com'è fatto il mio di armadillo È
una lana giudicante che parla romanaccio
ci manca solo di chiamarlo per nome si
chiama paura del fallimento
la paura del fallimento sono sicura la
conoscete tutti o magari conoscete bene
i suoi colleghi i suoi sintomi più
comuni Anzi da prestazione immobilismo
perdita di interesse bassa autostima
la paura del fallimento è quella che ci
impedisce dal fare il primo passo in
amore dal cambiare lavoro dal cambiare
università dal cambiare città dal salire
su un palco e fare un discorso
allora
io vorrei
arrivare a far sì che quando la paura
arrivi di nuovo a dirmi fallirai
io potrò rispondergli Daje zi
e nel farlo
voglio farvi un elogio al fallimento
voglio fargli proprio un epitaffio per
dare un senso al mio liceo classico
vorrei sconfiggerlo elevandolo
nell'olimpo insieme ai suoi colleghi più
attraenti e desiderati la vittoria e il
successo
un mio amico che è un bravissimo
produttore un giorno mi ha detto che
quando va a chiedere un sacco di soldi
per un film e loro gli chiedono cosa ha
fatto nella vita lui risponde io ho
fatto fallire una startup cioè con un
palo di vanto Cioè lui non va lì a
dirgli ho prodotto questo film di
successo no gli dice Io ho fallito e
quindi so come non fallire di nuovo
nello stesso modo ma soprattutto sono
uno che non ha paura di fallire ti osare
e quindi di fare
ho capito che la paura del fallimento
non ha senso Perché il successo non è
altro che una piramide fatta di mattoni
di tentativi falliti
a tutti piace vincere tutti
ma nessuno ha mai vinto senza prima
perdere e questa cosa la sappiamo tutti
È evidente Ma allora perché se sappiamo
che il fallimento è alla base di tutto
se il fallimento sono i tasselli
costitutivi della Vittoria e del
successo Perché la fuggiamo così
finiamo così
a stare lì come Se volessimo costruire
un palazzo ma avere paura a comprare i
mattoni e come vecchietti ai cantieri
stare lì a giudicare il coraggio di
costruire ce l'ha avuto veramente
è così La vita fa schifo la vita è
meravigliosa Yin e Yang bello e brutto
ci ostiniamo
a lottare contro l'evidenza che nella
vita per avere il bello devi avere il
brutto che per essere coraggioso devi
essere vulnerabile che per stare in
forma devi sottoporti a quella che
ritengo essere la peggiore tortura
moderna la palestra
è così ed è così in tutto
in e yang è Come direbbe la vocina Ah sì
stacce
E noi invece di starci con la più
fondamentale regola naturale stiamo lì a
dire io non sono d'accordo
ci ostiniamo a spingerci e a spingere
chi ci sta intorno a inseguire solo il
bello e a fuggire il brutto
e a volte ce la facciamo pure eh a non
fallire mai
si chiama
perfezionismo il finto antidoto al
fallimento e io Non per vantarmi Eh però
un paio di dottorati in merito quindi
sono abbastanza competente
il perfezionismo è un finto amico è un
sicario direttamente incaricato dalla
paura del fallimento
sembra nostro amico a prendere le
mazzette
vi faccio un esempio non mi sono mai
presentata a un esame all'università
senza essere certa di aver studiato
tutto cioè Bastava che io non sapessi un
piccolissimo paragrafo che dicevo Beh
non so niente non vado
Questa è la media di tutti gli esami che
ho fatto
bella eh sembra un successo direte voi
Anch'io lo pensavo Ma
in realtà ho capito
che se escludi il fallimento
della partita a poker non hai proprio
vinto in All in
se escludi il fallimento dal gioco
Non puoi dire di aver vinto davvero e
alla paura del fallimento mi piace
perdere e quindi mentre tu pensi di
fregare lei lei
ti rovina la vita
mentre prendevo quei voti bellissimi
all'università
ho perso tantissime amicizie un sacco di
occasioni importanti viaggi feste e un
amore importante
Adesso vi chiedo di pensare intimamente
a quante volte
avete giudicato voi stessi per aver
fallito a quante volte avete giudicato
gli altri per aver fallito
ma soprattutto a quante volte pur di non
fallire Avete vinto ma perdendo
adesso io lo so che questo discorso Vi
sembrerà assurdo fatto da una come me
che viene Ammirata per il suo coraggio
della ragazzina che sfida il maschilismo
né con le sue competenze in ambito
meccanico il suo rossetto rosso
mentre non si sa che la verità è che ho
il terrore delle telecamere e per colpa
dei bulli della mia infanzia un pessimo
rapporto con la mia immagine ma al
lavoro come content Creator mettendoci
la faccia
ho il terrore
dei ragni
e le auto d'epoca Ne sono piene ve lo
assicuro
ho paura del mare e dopo aver fatto anni
di vela agonistica Oggi faccio il
subacquea
ho il terrore di parlare in pubblico che
sono qui adesso davanti a voi
Se c'è una cosa che ho capito di me
è che il mio vero valore la mia vera
forza non sta nel non avere paura Ma
nella averne tantissima sempre ma odiare
di averla e odiare che mi definisca
Ed eccoci alla conclusione di questo che
è stato per me un'impresa
davanti a questo Ted che non parla di
quello di cui avrei voluto e che
comunque secondo il mio intransigente
giudice interiore poteva venire meglio
sono fiera di me per essere arrivata
tanto così da mollare ma non averlo
fatto
sono fiera di me per essermi concessa
finalmente
di mostrarmi imperfetta debole
impaurita
sincera umana il senso di completa nello
Yin e Nello Yang e il coraggio e nella
paura
adesso mentre al fallimento è stata
restituita la sua dignità e la paura
pende grondante Sì questa era quando
comunque non ci credevo di venirci
e la paura prende grondante di sangue
dalla mia mano
posso di nuovo guardare il mio cane che
è sceso dal suo piedistallo ed è venuto
a sdraiarsi accanto a me non più
disperata guardando negli occhi e
accettare che il suo sguardo dipende
unicamente dalla sua condizione genetica
e non da un giudizio nei miei confronti
e quindi Ringraziandovi
Vi auguro di fallire e di non averne
paura
Grazie
[Musica]